I never forced them to finish their
plates because I want them to have a
healthy relationship with you
them tell me their feelings by showing
me inside out figurines because
sometimes that's easier than putting
emotions into words this is becoming a
it seems like an increasingly popular
because I'm seeing on social media more
and more this thing about you don't want
to force your kid to eat because you
want them to have a healthy relationship
with food I guess the idea is that if
you force your kid to eat that you're
going to cause like eating disorders
down the line no that's not what it's
about there's a few things making your
kid eat the food that's on their plate
eat the food it's about teaching them
not to be wasteful you put food on the
plate and the kid doesn't eat it and
then you just throw it away is that a
healthy relationship with food to throw
good food away no you make them eat it
because it's about not being wasteful
it's also about being grateful you are
providing sustenance to your child
you're making meals for them you're
doing all that even though it's your
responsibility as a parent they should
still be grateful that you're doing it
and refusing to eat the food is uh is
not grateful